foreign
is with us in Albany New York hi Evan
how are you
hey guys how you doing better than we
deserve sir how can we help
yeah so um
me and my dad well he owns a business
I've been I've been only working here
for two years now but he's he's been
relapsing over the past year relapsing
relapsing sorry in what way I mean in a
drinking problem way and okay so he's an
alcoholic yeah he's back in the bottle
we're trying to run the business
yep wow I'm sorry
what's the business
say again sir what is the business
yeah it's a um Pest Control business
pest control and how old are you
I'm 20. and how many employees does he
have
uh almost 40.
and uh you're 20. how long has your dad
been drinking
um on and off for the past
15 20 years your whole life
yeah
and you've been running around trying to
clean up his message your whole life
uh I'm sorry yeah I'm sorry
that's hard
so what's your question Evan
I'm I'm just
well the bottom line is pretty much like
how do I get them back to work he's kind
of bed we're in right now yeah
yeah
um your mom gone
um developer divorce yeah yeah no
kidding not shocking okay
um has he put you in a leadership
position or are you just one of the
employees who happens to be his son what
kind of responsibility do you have for
the business
um I I do have some responsibility there
I'm one of the managers of the members
budget and advertising and billing but
we have like five other managers who
thank God know what they're doing and
are very good okay so the business is
doing well despite his absence
stop let's just stop okay the um the
advice I'm going to give you is going to
be very hard to hear are you ready to
hear it
yep okay
um there's a hole syndrome around adult
children of Alcoholics
you can look it up and start reading
about the symptoms of an adult child
that grew up in an alcoholic home
and one of the things that we see folks
that grow up like you've grown up is you
you've seen so much pain and there's so
much disaster in the wake of all the
alcoholism that you you feel like your
job is always to clean up the messes
and that's a standard reaction to this
situation
um if you were
my little brother if you were my nephew
if if if you and I could sit down
together in a cup of coffee I could put
my arm around you and give you a hug I
would right now and I would tell you
that it's time for you to stop saving
your father
he's gonna have to do that himself you
can do that as a loving son from a
distance but if I were you I would go
get a job somewhere else and build a
life somewhere else
and from a position of strength
emotionally and spiritually begin to do
some healing from what all you've been
through
and from that position of strength maybe
you can give your dad a little bit of
aid
with his alcoholism but it is not your
job Evan at 20 years old to save your
dad from the mess that he has made for
the last 15 years and that includes his
screwed up business life
you don't have that's not your job I
want to set you free from that
assignment it is not your assignment Run
please run for your sake
you know I I don't know if you'll do
that or not I don't know if you can hear
me say this or not but you need to be
free of this and it doesn't mean you
never speak to your dad again it doesn't
mean you're mean to your dad it doesn't
mean you're unkind to him or that you
yell at him because he's destroyed
everything with his drinking I'm not
telling you to do any of that I'm just
saying you have to have some separation
and go get some healing on your own
because dude what you have lived through
as a child has is wounding
it's and you know and the one of the
biggest symptoms is that adult children
of Alcoholics have to have everything
perfect
I have to have everything perfect
because their job was to keep up
appearances because Dad's laying in bed
drunk
and so my job is to go down and run the
businesses if he's not and it's it's a
form of denial and it comes out
specifically in this and I'm not a
psychologist Dr John deloney you might
want to talk to him uh I'll put you on
hope Kelly will set up time talk to him
on the air if you want he'll tell you
the same thing I'm telling you though
you've got to have some separation from
the situation in order to be of
assistance to your dad
and it's not your job young man
to fix all this
be free
it's not your job to fix this you didn't
break it it is not your duty to fix it
and you're not a bad son
by walking away from this the best thing
you can do for you and for your dad is
to walk away from this and then you can
give him Aid as a loving son from a
little more distance in a position of
healing
please go work somewhere else